[Music]
welcome to another episode of Whata
Prof hello Walter hello
Martin how are you doing why do you
always laugh when I say I like them way
you say
[Laughter]
it yes uh are you doing okay don't ask
okay so we'll just skip that part again
we'll skip that yeah especially when we
look in the mirror
[Laughter]
no let's open with a word of prayer we
need it need and yeah we definitely need
it our heavenly
father we need you every day every hour
and every minute please help us through
this discussion and that we can
enlight can get enlightened minds but by
what you want us to learn in Jesus name
amen
amen Martin we are busy talking about
preparation for what is
coming and uh we looked at world events
and we looked at the seriousness of the
times we are living in and the closeness
of the final
events and the question of course is how
do you get
ready and we're not talking about uh
planting vegetables now and no no that's
making sure that you you have a safe
haven and all of those things I'm
talking about
preparation for
heaven and that that's a tall order
right that is because because we a lot
of focus goes on on how to prepare for
the trouble yes but to prepare for
what's after the trouble the Blessed
hope yes that is a different story are
we ready to
be co- inhabiters with unfallen
beings it's a all order that's a tall
order right so let's look at being a
partaker of the divine
nature there were two
trees in the Garden of
Eden and these two trees were to
determine the path of
humanity so there were two choices you
either chose the one or he chose the
other
one there were not three and there were
not more than
three it is the issue of black and white
yeah there were no Shades of Gray
so two characters to develop either the
similitude of Satan or the similitude of
Christ and they had a choice mhm and
those two choices have remained
throughout history that's it right Satan
packaged the two choices in a thousand
variants 10,000
variants but they're just two packages
no more it's either the one or the other
nothing in between nothing in
between and it doesn't seem as if
people want to adopt the divine
nature they like to think about it they
like to even praise
it but to incorporate it that's a
different question right yeah because it
always has to do with letting go of
something yes so there are many many
verses in the Bible that talk about
being a
partaker so let's look at some of them
and see what you can be a partaker of
partaker is to be part and parcel of the
process to be one that is involved in it
and not only as an observer but a real
participant
M so when they saw the thief then thou
consent with him and has has been a
partaker with
adulterers all right so you can be a
adulterers and in a sense everybody in
humanity at some stage has probably been
a partaker with
adulterers this is a an
association but if you are a partaker
that means that you
relish their
activity and uh even if you don't
actually take part if you in your mind
let your mind wander in that direction
you've already become a partaker Right
Jesus said
so okay and you can be a partaker of
Hope
yeah he's all together for our sakes for
our sakes no doubt this is written that
he that plowe should plow hope and that
he that threshes in Hope should be
partaker of his
hope now this is talking about a
harvest but it has a much deeper meaning
a spiritual meaning right because to be
part of the Harvest you have to have a
certain mindset you have to have a
certain mindset you're
right or what about verse 23 of 1
Corinthians 9 and this I do for the
gospel's sake that I may be partaker
thereof with you so he wants to be part
and parcel of the Plan of
Salvation for if I by Grace be a
partaker why am I evil spoken of for
that for which I give
thanks so when you become a partaker you
become a partaker by Grace oh yeah
that's the only way not by anything that
you do no so in other words you become a
partaker but even that is a gift yeah
everything is a gift right from the very
beginning 1 Timothy 5:22 lay hands
suddenly on no man neither be partaker
of other men's sins keep thyselves
pure so don't get involved with anything
that is of a sinful nature otherwise you
become a
partaker you know the thing
is sometimes we lower the standard of
what is
sinful so a small white
lie is also actually a very serious
thing yeah you can actually say tell a
white lie for a good purpose that's
that's no but it's still a lie right
still a lie it's still a
lie I I had to deal with a little case
like that is
somebody wanted to justify a little
white
lie and uh well it it worked for
good but the question is is it morally
right that's the problem I mean was it a
white lie that Abraham told
Pharaoh it was a half truth but you can
justify you can you see that's the same
like a white lie you can almost justify
it but is it right
okay Jesus never lied right not once
according to the new translations he did
oh yes he said I am not going up to this
Feast but in the old translation in the
King James says I'm not yet going up to
this Feast so it's uh it's very
important if you don't
look at the little details you will
assume that Jesus told a white lie yeah
it's the same like the people blame him
that he actually broke the Sabbath yes
wow
okay 2 Timothy 1:8 be not thou therefore
ashamed of the testimony of Our Lord nor
of me his prisoner but be thou partaker
of the afflictions of The Gospel
According to the power of God God in
other words Martin if things are not
going so
well then uh don't necessarily blame
anyone or anything it's part of the
package that's it so if you want the
good and you want to be a partaker of
the good that means you must also be
prepared to be the partaker of the
consequences the backlash exactly it
actually goes both ways if you want to
be a part of AK of the other side you
must also be ready to partake of the
consequences okay second Timothy 26 the
husband man that labor must be first
partaker of the
fruits well that's a nice promise does
it always happen
no no no but that's how it should be
exactly and that's what's promised in
Heaven All right but now let's take it
to a spiritual level if you are a
laborer in another Vineyard in in a
spiritual Vineyard and this is actually
a promise that you'll be a partaker of
the fruits yes the first partaker of the
fruits that's quite a nice promise well
that's a beautiful one 1 Peter 51 the
elders which are amongst you I exort who
am also an elder and a witness of the
sufferings of Christ and also a partaker
of the glory that shall be
revealed that's confidence that's it so
first it was the suffering but the
reward the glory so much you will be a
partaker of all right but what is Glory
what does that stand for in the Bible no
character character Martin so you must
be a partaker of the character that
shall be
revealed so Heaven has a
particular Nuance a
character and that character in heaven
is in harmony with the character of
Christ so if you want to know what the
character of Heaven is going to be like
then you have to study the character of
Christ yeah 2 John 1:11 for he that bth
him God's speed is partaker of his evil
Deeds so if you say to someone I wish
you well when you know that he's on an
evil
Mission even if you don't take part in
the evil mission
or even if you say it uh basically to
avoid
conflict you become a partaker mar do
does one have to be very very
careful thinking of it yes it's amazing
how careful we should be how careful
were Adam and
Eve they
weren't you have to be careful they
didn't expect it right such a small
thing you see once again again we come
back to the small things they thought
God won't be so benign no no W happen
just something small like this he wow
well this scary one Matthew
23:30 and I say if we had been in the
days of our fathers we would not have
been partakers with them in the blood of
the prophets because Jesus said that
they were partakers and the blood of the
prophets even though they lived after
them
right and now the modern people say we
wouldn't have done that if they read
what it says they said we wouldn't have
done that but they've already
transgressed because they actually did
M because didn't Jesus die for them
exactly why did he have to die for them
because of sin because they were
partakers you're part yeah we were all
partakers of the blood of the prophet
phets because the prophets all testified
of Christ and we are responsible for the
blood of Christ therefore we are
responsible for all the prophets yeah
cuz they bore the same message it's
still relevant today Romans
15:27 it has pleased them verily and
they debors they are for if the Gentiles
have been made partakers of their
spiritual things their duty is also to
minister unto them in carnal
things so we have to become partakers of
the spiritual
things but when we do that we must also
be a partaker in the carnal things we
must also take care of them yeah you
minister to them you have to minister to
them you can't just no leave it like you
mentioned before so if you just want to
ditch
somebody yeah it's not no then you'll
have a
problem uh didn't Jesus said I will be
with you always yeah so were you ever
ditched no no never ditches you right
can we do the same we have to not ditch
anybody yeah okay so if others be
partakers of this power over you are not
we rather so you can
have power over someone mhm somebody can
look up to you and think you're
wonderful when in actual fact you might
not be so wonderful
right nevertheless we have not used this
power but suffer all things lest we
should hinder the gospel of Christ so
when you
are in Christ you are part partaker of
his power mhm but that's a
responsibility that's a big
responsibility not to misuse it okay 1
Corinthians 9:13 do you not know that
they which minister about holy things
live of the things of the temple and
they which wait at the altar are
partakers with the altar
so if you become involved in the things
of
Christ it is all
encompassing all
encompassing eventually you become so
involved that you also become a partaker
of the benefits that come with it yeah
yeah so Martin have you changed your
life have you gone from a secular world
to a world where you are totally
dependent on Ministry for
sure yeah and was it a risk for you for
sure it it's a worldly risk were you
worried I think think I was yes we were
quite worried but then when you start
letting I I don't think there's anybody
that's not worried once they have to
start doing the decision to go that
route okay and what is it involved I
mean I had the same thing I was working
at the
University I was the head of a
department I had a
professorship and I had to make a choice
to go into
Ministry and and it's a it's a scary
choice because basically you're dropping
your worldly anchor yeah getting rid of
it you're actually cutting it off that's
that's where the scary part is there's
nothing to fall back on nothing yeah so
in other words you have to have faith
because once you've cut that cord you're
on your own pal absolutely so what what
does it involve trust and faith that's
it everything and even if that faith is
pathetic once you take that step it
grows quickly did he ever drop you after
that not once and in actual fact it's if
you put yourself in the position like
the Israelites before they went into the
Jordan River yes it's the same thing
they were probably standing there
worried about
everything there they knew that they had
to take a step and put their foot in the
water and would
open when it was it the Red Sea God
still yeah yeah he was he was still
prepared to overlook their their
unbelief and he opened it for them
before they went in because they were
muttering and screaming and moaning
exactly not at the
Jordan there you have to put your foot
in the altar so if you want to be a
partaker of the altar then you have to
minister at the altar I don't know
Martin I think many people will will be
called in the near future I think it's
already happening to put their hands to
the
plow 1 Corinthians
1017 for we being many are one bread and
one body for we are all partakers of
that one bread behold Israel after the
flesh are they not which eat of the
sacrifices partakers of the altar it's
the same question but now's actually
said we're all partakers of one bread
we're all part of Christ that's it the
bread of
life uh are all the characters the same
that are the partakers of the bread no
does that rile you
sometimes we work through it you work
through it okay but now think about it
you're going to go to heaven one day
exactly by Grace yeah and those same
characters might be there exactly oh
they're not going to be you see that's a
wonderful thing we're all partakers of
the one bread so all will be of one mind
but not necessarily one
personality okay and we don't know who
is where on his spiritual
journey so we have to be
patient we have to be
longsuffering we have to develop have to
develop all those character
trays in order
to be as the Bible says partakers of the
Lord's table Yeah you cannot drink the
cup of the Lord and the cup of devils
who cannot be partaker of the Lord's
table and of the table of
devils what kind of spiritual food are
you consuming you can't be partaker of
them both oh even what are you listening
to what are you
watching now why don't I've come across
people that
say I will I will partake of this
food and spit out the Pips yeah I've
heard that have you heard that mhm in
other words I'll keep that which is good
and spit out that which is not
acceptable you see so the problem is
they take that Bible verse and estort it
because where Jesus says test the spirit
and hold on to what's good it doesn't
mean go and test everything that there
is like alcohol and drugs and smoke and
see what's good in it there's nothing
good in it no and in a false prophet or
in a false prophecy
mhm uh the devil likes to let the LIE
ride on the back of truth of course so
so can you keep the truth and spit out
the Pips or is it better to stick with
the truth from the beginning that's it
so if you
have books like we've done one on the
apocryphal books we've showed how many
Pips are in those books so why would you
run to go through that yeah you don't
have to go to that if you have The Real
McCoy right I always ask if you believe
that we've got the spirit of Prophecy
given through by God there's 100,000
plus pages to read once you've G get
gone through all of those then you can
start reading something else okay all
right but sometimes inadvertently stuff
comes your way and then you have to use
discernment oh for sure but don't put
yourself In Harm's Way from the
beginning yeah right the Bible says that
if you want to be part of the hope then
you have to be part of the suffering
we've dealt with that and to be a
partaker is more than being an
observer but the great thing is that the
Gentiles should be fellow heirs and of
the same body and partakers of his
promise in Christ by the
gospel wonderful that you can become
partakers of the promise now this
promise was given to Abraham wasn't it
yeah I know that's true all
everybody that is the seed of is in
Christ is the Seed of Abraham all right
now would you think Martin that this
verse in Ephesians
3 uh would have irritated some
of the
Israelites oh definitely because they
were the chosen they were the chosen
ones and now he's telling them no no no
the Gentiles are now also partakers of
the promise in
Christ and there are still people today
who say that certain people are excluded
mhm so must we develop a mindset of
inclusiveness M
if we want to go to heaven you can't be
prejudiced against whatever yeah against
the race or prejudiced against this that
or the other you have to accept that all
have sinned and fall short that's it so
in Christ all are brothers and sisters
all are brothers and sisters but only in
Christ that's it that's where the Crux
lies right here's another one we don't
have to read all the verses you can be a
partaker of the ground R mhm you can be
a partaker of the benefit mhm you can be
a partaker of Flesh and
Blood now that's a very interesting one
this has go through Hebrews 2:14 for as
much then as the children are partakers
of Flesh and Blood he also himself
likewise took part of the same that
through death he might destroy him that
had power over death that is the devil
so Christ I
identified 100% with Humanity Yeah by
becoming 100% human flesh and blood
flesh and blood and in that sense we
become Brethren of Christ beautiful
that's quite quite a promise H
yeah now let's get a little bit
complicated with Hebrews wherefore holy
Brethren partakers of the heavenly
calling consider the Apostle and high
priest of our profession Christ
Jesus we are partakers of a Heavenly
calling it's a very high standard yeah
that has to be reached you become a
partaker of
Christ but you also become a partaker of
the Holy Ghost
m in other words you must come into
harmony with Heavenly thinking
completely completely because that
Heavenly thinking is where we are going
all right now that Heavenly thinking is
it in harmony with your nature no
totally
opposite so but when it comes to Hebrews
chapter 6 from verse four
onwards where he says that you must
become a partaker of the Holy
Ghost but if you turn your back on
it yeah then you're actually crucifying
Christ
again to be a partaker of the Holy Ghost
must mean to be so convinced of the
truth that to reject it afterwards is
actually crucifying Christ CHR again but
the bottom line is you must be a
partaker of the Holy Ghost okay there's
a lot of people that are very scared
about the part that says the sin against
the Holy Ghost yes maybe you can just
briefly explain what that means the sin
against the Holy Ghost well the sin
against the Holy Ghost Martin is when
you say that that which is of god is of
the devil yeah that is the sin against
the Holy Ghost Jesus said the sins
against him will be
forgiven in other words if you say I
know it's the truth but I don't want to
do it that can be
forgiven or the sin of not doing what is
what you are told m but knowing that
it's wrong that's not the sin against
the holy spirit because the holy spirit
is still telling you that it's wrong
that's the main point but when the Holy
Spirit doesn't tell you that it's wrong
and you actually think it's right and
that which is right you think is from
the devil then then you have committed
that sin so that's important just to let
people know that once
you've fallen and you ask for
forgiveness that's not the sin against
the Holy Ghost the sin against the Holy
Ghost no matter how bad that process was
but you have to become a partaker of the
Holy Ghost in other words you have to
receive the
mindset and then you have the good news
that if you receive that mindset and the
only way to receive it is through
chastisement MH because the old nature
must be clobbered out of
you if you don't have the CH
chastisement then you become
bastards and not sins so if you want to
have it then you must be partaker of the
chastisement as well in other words take
it like a man yeah yeah stop
wincing and this is a very difficult one
you must be a
partaker of his Holiness yeah that is
the main one Holiness what is Holiness
Martin we got a definition for me of
Holiness there's only one that's holy
and that's God that's God and the only
one who has manifested God to us is
Jesus Jesus so so in other words if you
want to be holy you have to emulate
Christ that's it that's the only way
nothing on Earth is Holy okay it must be
Jesus so to be be holy means to be in
harmony with
Christ it also means there's one
definition that I quite like it also
means that you have to be in
agreement with God
yeah and how do you become one that
agrees with God that means you must have
worked your way through this
Bible and even the hard
verses yep you must have muled them
over and thought to yourself why would
God do this and if you've thought it
through then you will realize there was
no other way let's say the destruction
of Sodom and Gomorrah do you think there
were many people who were displeased
with the destruction of Sodom and
Gomorrah for sure how many Israelites
were displeased with the destruction of
Kora and his clan a lot didn't they
murmur the very next day didn't they
blame Moses yep so the ways of God are
not always easy to understand
and you have to understand the character
of God is it misunderstood today oh
definitely yes everybody misunderstands
him right why does God permit this and
you take an insurance company they tell
you that when your house is flooded it's
an act of God po God who said it was an
act of God why wasn't it an act of the
devil exactly who did the destruction in
job's day not God he permitted it he
permitted it well then he's to blame
because he could have prevented it and
you hear that as well you hear that as
well so this is a very tricky one you
have to be a partaker of the Holiness
now it's not enough to agree with
someone no you actually have to do it
all right I agree that eating this and
that and the other is bad for me I know
it is but I'm going to do it anyway
agreeing is not is not enough doing
anything about it even so if you want to
be a partaker of the divine nature uhhuh
then agreeing is essential but doing
adhering to or doing is just as
essential and Martin will you be a
partaker of Christ's suffering if you
accept this truth it's a promise whereby
are given us unto us exceeding great and
precious promises that by these you
might be partakers of the divine nature
and this is what we're going to talk
about yeah to become a partaker of the
divine
nature having escape the corruption that
is in the world through
lust and this is the state we must
achieve before we can go to heaven it's
a tall order but it's necessary and
that's the only way and we may not be
partakers with babylon's
sins in other words you must make right
choices based on on the Bible
right so there are only two choices
you're either the partaker of the divine
nature or you are a partaker of her sins
sins is the transgression of the
law and that's the choice that we have
to make now I'm sure that many would
like to make the choice that leads to
heaven but it implies be becoming a
partaker of the divine nature and that
it requires some that requires some
effort right mhm and if we are really
very close to the end now and I believe
we are I me youo history is winding
up when the call goes out the bridegroom
cometh and The Virgins wake up half of
them don't have oil right
no and uh did they enter no no they ran
to get oil yeah but by the time that
they came back the door was closed was
closed so Martin before that takes place
isn't it necessary that we become
partakers of the divine
nature absolutely so after the fall of
Man Satan declared that human beings
were proved to be incapable of keeping
the law of God and he sought to carry
the UN Universe with him in this
belief Satan's words appeared to be true
and Christ came to unmask the deceiver
the Majesty of Heaven undertook the
cause of man and with the same
facilities that man May obtain with stod
the Temptations of Satan as man must
withstand them this was the only way in
which Fallen man could become a partaker
of the divine nature so only by Christ's
coming could we become partakers of the
divine nature because he being fully
human was also fully Divine yeah it's
the only way he had to come otherwise
Humanity would have been lost and is
there a war against that in the world
yes most religions deny the Divinity of
Christ
right in taking human nature Christ was
fitted to understand man's trials and
sorrows and all the Temptations
wherewith He is is beset Angels who were
unacquainted with sin could not
sympathize with man in his peculiar
trials Christ condescended to take man's
nature and was tempted in all points
like as we that he might know how to
sucker all who should be tempted in
assuming Humanity Christ took the part
of every human being he was the head of
humanity a being divine and human with
his long human arm he could encircle
Humanity while with his Divine arm he
could lay hold of the Throne of the
infinite so if you just study that a
little bit the only way to be a partaker
of the divine nature mhm is by placing
your absolute trust to achieve this in
Christ that's it CU you can't do it
without him no so in a sense Satan was
was right that man cannot keep the law
yeah but he was wrong in the sense that
if you are connected to God you can keep
the law that's where he's wrong so all
right so the connection was severed when
Adam and Eve sinned that's it but by
promise it was brought back and then in
actuality it was brought back when
Christ came to this world so actually
Satan is lying to you true why does he
not want to or cannot keep the law
because he has no connection no he has
no connection he has no he doesn't have
the one that has the arm to grasp the
infinite all right so if you say I want
that
connection you have to open the door y
but in order for him to come in the
garbage has to go out uhuh
okay so in so far as we lack Perfection
of character thus far do we fail of
attaining that which God has provided
for us through Jesus Christ if we do not
lay hold upon the provision of his grace
we shall have a cheap experience
governed by our own
impetus changeable disposition we cannot
glorify God by our own
efforts we must become partakers of the
divine nature abiding in him as the
branches abide in the
vine so Martin how do you do this that's
the answer is right there that's it the
only re way is it to to cling onto
Christ you have to slot into with him
all right and when you do that you have
to give up self yeah and how often do
you have to clob a self today
every con constantly every day
constantly as long as we have a fallen
nature we will have a battle and the
closer you get to Christ the harder that
clobbering gets because it's going to be
severe and because the closer you get
the more sinful you appear in your own
eyes the whole
time all right here's another question
what about without the divine nature
everything that God could do has been
done for the Salvation of man in one
rich gift he poured out the treasures of
Heaven he invites he pleads he urges but
he will not compel men to come unto him
he never forces anyone right it's an
invitation do you force anybody to come
to your invitation I wish I
could he waits for their cooperation he
waits for the consent of the will that
he may bestow upon the sinner the rich
Riches of his grace reserved for him
from the foundation of the world a man
does not build himself into a habitation
for the spirit and unless there is a
co-operation of man's will with God's
will the Lord can do nothing for him can
you see how important it is to agree
with God for
sure though the Lord is the Great Master
worker yet the human agent has his part
to act with the divine Divine worker or
the Heavenly building cannot be
completed all the power is of god yet
all the responsibility rests with the
human agent for God can do
nothing without the cooperation of man
the Lord does not design that human
power should be paralyzed but that by
cooperation with God man may become a
more efficient agent in his hand so the
the bottom line is if I want this to
work my will has to be in harmony with
God's will yeah that when you say you
mentioned just before and I was thinking
that we have to agree with
God but you mentioned Also earlier that
you cannot just say yes I agree but not
do anything that is in harmony again
yes now you're right so if you look at
this question from the point of view of
wanting to become a partaker of the
divine
nature you have to
intellectually decide that God's way is
the better way your nature will rebel
against it instantly let's say God's way
take the example that irritates
everyone if you eat like this you will
will be healthy etc etc so go back to
the identic way of eating will your
nature rebel against it immediately
immediately so intellectually you have
to say to yourself I am convinced that
God's way is the better way then I have
to ask myself the
question if I am so inclined to this
other way because of my pallet mhm does
that that mean God wants to withhold Joy
from me that's your question you have to
ask immediately so is God now a tyrant
that is wanting to take this away from
me or has my pallet become so perverted
that I do not appreciate that which is
of a Kinder gentler nature yeah that's
that's what happened all right so what
would be the next step then you would
have to say to yourself if you intellect
know that God Is Right mhm then you have
to cooperate that is it so agreeing
needs cooperation all right then you
have to say to God okay I want to
cooperate help me oh yes because
immediately the devil will say you
cannot do it no and why should you do it
because God is withholding something
from you okay so you say all right this
is bad for me I'm going to take away
then you take it away and you've made an
intellectual
decision uh that doesn't mean you will
be jumping for joy right then not but
then as you get used to the new
one and you have become a partaker MH of
this
way eventually over time if you look
back to the old way how do you feel
about the old way I look back and I am
actually disgusted appalled appalled
appalled right but it is a process and
it's not easy no because when you were
there you couldn't you were actually
making fun of where I am now yes all
right now once you've achieved it you've
become a partaker and you see things as
God sees us and you actually relish it
you think wow this is such a magnificent
Improvement in in my life
uh are you then holy no not at all
because how many other areas are there
where the same thing applies no it's the
whole time everything
right your temper your disposition the
way
that you speak and think everything but
I must also say that when you agree with
God and you start cooperating with him
some of those things get better and they
it's a constant getting better all right
we're talking about end times we're
talking about preparation for going to
heaven and let's say if we look at this
process and we look at ourselves we see
we fall far short yeah now there are
some things where we have actually
adopted the divine nature and many where
we have rejected it
yeah so what is it what is it that we
need to do in the time we live live and
we need to do
introspection and we have to like
uh like David we have to say search my
heart yes see if there's any wicked
thing in it tell me and then wash me
yeah tell me wash me and then in order
to be
washed I must actually go to the car
wash yeah I must permit him to wash me
yes that means I must permit him to take
away that which is old that's what every
one of us should be
doing at this time in which we are
living though weak ering frail sinful
and imperfect the Lord holds out to man
the privilege of co-partnership with him
is that the solution that's the only
solution all right so Martin what are we
weak we are weak yeah are we earing are
we frail are we sinful are we imperfect
all of them apply right so if this with
a multiple choice that would have to add
one all of the above
yeah believing in Jesus as his personal
savior accepting of his righteousness by
faith The Sinner becomes a partaker of
the divine nature and escapes the
corruption that is in the world through
lust but there are people that think
that this doesn't require a change you
just put on a different garment and
there you go you see that's where my
problem is um once you just agree with
God you have to become a
co-partner from through Jesus
otherwise you're going to just stuck
where you are all right so the Garment
is not there to cover up your
imperfections no you have to become a
doer in order to qualify for the Garment
yeah okay and then it is through the
indwelling of the holy spirit that the
Christian is enable to resist
temptation and to work righteousness
without the divine nature without the
influence of the spirit of God man
cannot work out his own salvation this
is so
important so your salvation is by faith
and by faith alone but it is made
manifest by doing
MH and if you are not doing then you
have to ask God to actually enable you
to do yeah or else you are rejecting the
Garment that's serious you have to ask
for help can you do a patchwork garment
a little bit of Christ and a little bit
of you no Christ wore a seamless garment
okay because you he said you can't patch
the Garment because the new will make
the other one shrink or what other
whatever
Christ said without me you can do
nothing the Fallen race could be
restored only through the Merit of him
who was equal with God though so highly
exalted Christ consented to take upon
Him human nature that he might work in
behalf of man and reconcile to God his
disloyal subjects Christ pleads his
Merit on our behalf now there are people
say and the devil says you can't h
but this actually says You must yeah now
when Jesus said to the lady called
caught in
adultery go and sin no more was he
telling her an impossibility
no no otherwise what was the point of
telling her go and sin no more there's
no point
then you remember that example we use of
the alcoholic yeah you're an alcoholic
but you make a cognitive decision I'm
going to stay away from alcohol that's
it you're still an alcoholic that's it
but you don't drink
anymore so if you do this in
relationship to sin who gives you the
strength to actually do it the Holy
Spirit the Holy Spirit does it right so
in a sense the Holy Spirit actually is
helping an alcoholic as well oh for sure
because without the impulse of the Holy
Spirit he wouldn't even want to give it
up no okay so whenever you still have a
guilty conscience you know the holy
spirit is at work okay so as our
substitute and sity he undertook to
combat the powers of darkness in our
behalf and prevailed against the enemy
of our souls presenting to us the cup of
Salvation bottom line is in this Warfare
who enables you to say no only the holy
spirit so if you are tempted what do you
do you ask help you run to Christ yeah
right
yeah in fact we are admonished to
sing yeah sing A Hymn that's it devil
doesn't like Hy no so the Prince of Life
consented to Bear insult and mockery
pain and death upon the cross of Calvary
he paid redemption's price for a lost
world it was the world that he loved the
one lost sheep that he would bring back
to his
fold the cross of Calvary speaks the
amazing love of God for the sinner he
valued him at an infinite price giving
his only begotten son that whosoever I
love that word
whosoever believe the should not perish
but have ever everlasting
life and if you realize this then the
rest follows if the love of God fails to
call forth a response from the human
heart if it fails to soften and subdue
the soul we are utterly
lost there's no reserved power you see
nothing else Heaven can do to subdue
your soul is to really let God help you
and not say but I am only human and God
knows my heart and therefore I can carry
on what I have been doing before we can
so this is really an
appeal for thorough
introspection and asking God to do for
us what we are incapable of doing for
ourselves and then not to forget m that
he is the one who did it L I become
puffed up and say how great I
am you see the devil has a lot of
ammunition he always tricks you up
because now you've really done good but
then it goes back to you instead of back
to you if you take the glory to yourself
that's what happened to Solomon yeah
Solomon says I'm young I do not know how
to come in and how to go
out and then later he became conf
confident in himself and that led to his
downfall and how far did he
fall right down barely made it he barely
made it have you failed to respond to
the pleadings of his Spirit then no
longer fortify your heart in hardness
open the door of the heart to receive
Christ the best give of Heaven let not
cruel unbelief influence you to refuse
the Heaven Sent guest let not Christ say
of you you will not come unto me that
you might have
life with loving in treaties he follows
the sinner pleading turn ye turn ye for
why will you die oh House of
Israel so that's the bottom line and
this is where we should be in this day
and
age all right now there's a theory and
there's a practical application we must
look at the practical application right
yeah yeah all right we don't have to
read it all Martin but we must get a
certain message out of
this so what a blessed experience it is
our privilege to have the old
temperament must be cast
out and when this work is complete true
spiritual gifts will be revealed in us
we must look and live the of the Holy
Spirit ever thirsting is the secret of
life in Christ under its power we are
ever receiving and ever
imparting mtin if you do not impart then
you cannot receive yeah so if you've
received or everything you don't give
anything back or try and tell to anybody
else it's what is it worth all right
will you often be rebuked when you
imparted yeah but probably most of the
time all right so that's part of the
equation yeah that's the sufferings that
we've read then you can become better or
better you have to make a choice between
the
two so under its power we are ever
receiving and ever imparting that's very
important we have a great work to do for
the master but if we keep ourselves in
our own hand and do not trust the Lord
implicitly really realizing that we are
kept by his power we shall find we have
a job on hand that brings to us very
little Heavenly
Joy so you have to be a partaker of the
work you have to be a partaker of the
suffering and you have to be a partaker
of his
nature now let's drop down where the
Lord said to Abraham when he was 99
years old I am the almighty God walk
before me and be thou
perfect does that scare you oh yes okay
our work is to be of one Accord
mhm so if we want to be
perfect then uh we have to ask God how
to achieve this
yep now fortunately Martin when it comes
to being perfect it says our
justification is by Faith mhm in a risen
ascended savior who is fully able to do
this work in an
instant that's so whereas sanctification
is the work of a lifetime still through
the inworking of the Holy Spirit yes so
today tomorrow follow on to know the
Lord that we may know that his going
forth is prepared as the
morning this is the reception of the
Holy Spirit to know God and Jesus Christ
whom he has sent now it's very important
that we know God yeah I'm actually
working on a sermon what does it mean to
know God if you know God if you really
know him then you will want to emulate
him yeah and if you really want to
emulate him you will do the
works but it will never be you doing the
works it will be he doing the works
because we have a fallen nature and of
our own nature we will not do
it because we are selfish Y and he was
100% unselfish so what how do you
replace selfishness with 100%
unselfishness you
can't we have to live God has to do it
for us yeah so in other words we have to
reflect Christ's image we shall love one
another as he loved
us so all we can do is reflect his image
so it is actually he that is working in
us you know the thing is also we can say
all of this but how do you do it how do
you know what Christ wants and how what
his image is like if you don't study the
word because if you don't study you
won't know what is all of the his
character like all right so you're right
Martin and if we
are
Christlike then we shall not love as we
love our neighbor but as Christ loved us
so like so not like you love your
neighbor but how how he loves your
neighbor do you always love your
neighbor no well you should you should
but things happen
so actually you can say do you always
love your brother
the the brothers all of them you have a
number of Brothers yeah are they always
very kind to you no but you love them
still you still love them you should do
that with everybody now that's you know
the story of Peter where he fell and
Jesus asked him three times do you love
me oh yeah yeah uh it's such a marvelous
story because Peter admitted that he
wasn't capable of agapo Love agape love
couldn't he couldn't Master it and Jesus
asked him do you Agape me do you Agape
me but then he came down to his L do you
filo me and he realized he couldn't yeah
but later in Peter's lad his final step
is agape so he's saying you can do it
but he first had to die it yourself
that's it because Agape is unselfish
love okay it's only other
centered so we must have that love else
we cannot be perfect before God and as
Peter
realized that if you turn your eyes away
from Jesus then you will never attain to
it yeah unless we love as Christ love
our Candlestick will be removed out of
its
place that does that mean that we must
even love those that are not very
lovable well does Christ love them yes
so that's your that's your
requirement how about the
Satanist to have to have the same
compassion that Christ had how about
political
figures is always easy to love them all
it's never easy but that's the thing it
wasn't easy for Christ either all right
how um you don't have to agree with what
they're doing and you don't have to love
the sin but you must love the person all
right how impartial must you be in order
to love everyone completely but that's
not easy all right how how impartial
must you be if you want to save those
that hate
you you have to have some
endurance okay so we need a daily
conversion yeah especially if they've
riled you up yeah then you have to ask
God to put that love back into your into
your system right no if it's the same
with you
but the closer your relationship with
Christ it seems the more people want to
rile you up okay then you get to the
point where you have to say Save Me In
Spite of myself my poor weak un
Christlike self mold me fashion me raise
me into a pure and holy atmosphere where
the rich current of thy love can flow
through my soul
M you actually at war with your nature
all time it's a war so the greatest
battle we all have to face is the battle
with
self and we cannot win the battle
without Christ it's
impossible so the bottom line is we must
reveal that love that dwelt in Christ
Jesus so Martin as we
prepare for communion with Heavenly
beings
ask yourself is there anyone that you
really find Despicable in the
world and then ask the Lord to make you
feel the same compassion for that person
as he had for that person when he went
to the Cross yeah that's where you have
to end up with and if your answer is
that you cannot cannot do that you've
got a problem then you've got a problem
right you see and that is especially
like we've shown in the in the past few
weeks the
agitation in the
world that's the only way that that can
be solved but unfortunately on this
Earth it's not going to be completely
solved Jesus has to come to make an end
to it all right the world is at
enmity and the enmity is increasing and
at this very moment moment as we are
sitting
here are there people killing other
people yeah are there Wars going on are
they throwing bombs on people yeah all
over the
place Christ unites in his person the
fullness and Perfection of the godhead
and the fullness and Perfection of
sinless humanity there is not one iot of
sinful Humanity in him because the Bible
says he was without sin M and he said
the devil is coming he has nothing on me
nothing there's absolute
sinlessness and will you have to be
sinless to go to heaven yes but not on
your own not on your own I cannot stand
there but to have a spot without spot or
wrinkle that means without sin but it
can only be Christ's
spotless so met all the Temptations by
which Adam was assailed and overcame
these
Temptations because in his Humanity he
relied upon divine power do we have that
capacity to rely on divine power yes we
have therefore the devil is a liar when
he says you can't keep the law exactly
because he are he is actually
saying you cannot have a connection with
God yeah that's true that's what he says
isn't that a negation of Christ yeah so
he's saying Christ has no no purpose and
no role to play so you have to call him
out on this and uh call his bluff and
tell him you're a liar exactly and you
can use scripture to prove it okay this
subject demands far more contemplation
than it receives Christians strike too
low they are content with a superficial
spiritual experience and therefore they
have only the glimmer WIS of light when
they might discern more clearly the
wonderful Perfection of Christ's
Humanity which Rises far above all human
greatness all human power Christ's life
is a revelation of what Fallen human
beings may
become through the union and fellowship
with the divine nature so it's not on
your own it's only through coer through
Christ now have you tried to explain
that to your
wife or let me put it the other way has
your wife often tried to explain that to
you um that I'm not
holy that you have to become a fellow of
the divine nature yeah yeah well first
you hear that you're not holy and then
you hear the rest that you have to
become part of the divine nature all
right now what does it do Martin does it
RI you or does it lead you to content
cont
lation it's supposed to lead you to
contemplation that's why you have a wife
right that's why you have a wife and
neighbors and all of these people it's
not good for man to be alone he needs to
be
corrected now the Holy Spirit does it
but often he get some help get a little
bit of
help we're going to be in trouble
again
well we're laughing but it's a very very
serious matter and just by looking at
our relationships with those around us
we see how desperately we need more of a
Divine introspection a
cooperation so M when Paul wanted to
show the condescension of the savior in
their
behalf presenting Christ as he was one
equal with God and with him receiving
the homage of the
Angels the Apostle traces his course
until he had reached the lowest depth of
humiliation so here is
God coming right down being subject to
the wickedness of man
MH in its extreme outpouring yeah so
Paul was convinced that if they could be
brought to comprehend the the amazing
sacrifice made by the Majesty of Heaven
All selfishness would be banished from
their lives now did it always happen no
no because they didn't open the door now
we're talking to fellow Believers
now those who want to receive the
outpouring of the holy spirit this is a
very serious
issue how do we get
ourselves to be
accepting rather
than those in the time of Paul were
rejecting you have to contemplate the
Majesty of heaven and if you see how he
operated and what he did in your behalf
all selfishness should be taken away
right well I was just thinking if you
take when Christ was crucified or
everything that he suffered for there
was not one accusation through his whole
life that was true of other people
against him everything was a lie and did
he ever retaliate no so that makes has
to let you think because we get very
riled up when people do us wrong yes or
even when somebody says something wrong
yeah when they accuse you falsely and
that happens often even say for instance
me and my wife if we if we are talking
then that's most of the time where the
problem comes in you want to retaliate
you want to retaliate and that so Paul
showed how the Son of God had laid aside
his glory voluntarily subjecting himself
to the conditions of human nature and
then had humbled himself as a servant
becoming obedient unto death even the
death of a cross that he might lift
Fallen man from degradation to Hope and
joy and heaven so so is is Heaven on our
side yes Heaven wants us to
succeed are we on Heaven's side
no this is a terrible dichotomy how are
we going to overcome it we need to spend
a thoughtful hour every day
contemplating The Life of Christ and
then asking God
to achieve the same in house clean house
clean house so he abased himself to
humanity that he might reach man's
sunken in the depth of Woe and
degradation and lift him up into a
nobler
life a noble life so M if you are
inclined not to be
Noble if you're inclined to be morose
what Christ ever morose no never right
not once does it ever say that he was
morose no no was he sad oh yes many
times many times he actually wept many
times and who did he weep for mostly for
his children for the believing that he's
the Israelites for the ones who rejected
him yeah
right so Jesus cares for each
one as though there were not another
individual on the face of the earth oh
that's beautiful can we achieve that
no only Christ can help you to achieve
that okay because and that is so you
cannot even think of that no if that
were if only you were living on Earth
Christ would still have died for you
have died for you so as deity he exerts
Mighty power in our our behalf while as
our elder brother he feels for all our
woes the Majesty of Heaven held not
himself aloof from degraded sinful
humanity and neither should we no
everybody is a potential child of God
yeah everybody it doesn't matter how
degraded they are we have not a high
priest who is so high so lifted up that
he cannot notice us or sympathize with
us but one who was in all points tempted
like as we are yet without sin so this
is the preparation that we need in the
time that we are living
in it is no degradation for man to bow
down before his maker and confess his
sins and plead for forgiveness through
the merits of a crucified and Risen
Savior it is Noble to acknowledge your
wrongs before him whom you have wounded
by transgression and Rebellion wasn't I
once had someone say to me God does not
expect me to
gravel God does not expect me to
gravel uh God doesn't really want anyone
to gravel I would admit to that but if
you have have
sinned you should be able to bow down in
Repentance before God yeah but uh some
people believe that they've been put in
a position of
power and uh divine right of kings for
example and they believe that this power
has been given to them and therefore
Everybody Must acknowledge it and they
never have to apologize but everyone
must apologize to them yeah you see I
think sometimes they take out of context
the place where David didn't want to
touch the anointed of God when he cut
the mantle off from Soul yes because if
you want to if you if you twist that
then you'll say okay so you won't you
once you're a chosen of God you're
untouchable yes and that's not true you
have as a chosen of God if you are God's
chosen you still have a big
responsibility but David showed a lot of
compassion and kindness which he didn't
receive in return no but that's the
nature of that's the thing so so that
even makes it more when you're in a
responsible
position then you have so much more to
be humble
and a servant towards the others all
right Martin so it is no degradation for
man to bow down before his maker yeah
now human beings are generally proud
beings and they hate to admit that they
are
wrong and uh uh if you are in an
argument with someone particularly
someone that's close to you it's
sometimes even harder to admit that you
are wrong but uh it is not a degradation
it is actually an
elevation to admit that you were wrong
oh for sure so all of us have sinned and
fall short of the glory of God all of us
need to bow down and to confess our
faults be and our sins to God
we must confess our sins to God and our
faults to one another so it is Noble to
acknowledge your wrong before him whom
you have wounded by transgression and
Rebellion remember he's
unfallen uh it's very hard for man to
perceive that there is a being that's
never wrong
yeah now I have been in this faith for
what 38
years and I've never won an argument
with God no I've lost every single one
that I've have had with him it's not a
good track record no unfortunately in
terms of Victory but you know what Satan
has also not won one yet no he hasn't
won one either yet but and he won't ever
all right now but often I want to
justify
myself we all I don't think there's any
human that has not tried that yes and if
you want to justify yourself then you
sermonize
uhhuh my wife tells me when I pray and I
pray long about something she says you
you're you're giving a
sermon God doesn't want the sermon he
wants you to say to him where you're
wrong you have to fix it up yeah God
bless us Soul so it lifts you up before
men and angels for he that humbleth
himself shall be exalted but he who
kneels before Fallen man and opens in
confession the secret thoughts and
imaginations of his heart is dishonoring
himself by debasing his manhood and
degrading every noble Instinct of his
soul in unfolding the sins of his life
to a priest corrupted with the wine and
licentiousness his standard of character
is lowered and he is defiled in
consequence God is degraded in his
thought to the likeness of sinful
Humanity
for the priest stands as a
representative of God whoa Martin this
destroys a whole religious system in
this world yeah so why would she write
like
this because the standard that God has
and the Holiness that God has is
degraded to the level of a human being
when you do these things that's why the
Bible says the secret sins belong to God
you confess your sins to God you are
never degraded when you confess to God
but repentance requires that you turn
from what you did and don't do it
anymore a human being can never forgive
you your sins no even the Bible says
only God can forgive you your sins so
bottom line is after serious
introspection it's time to confess that
we were wrong yeah every single one of
us and even if we think we were right
then we were wrong in the way in which
we portrayed this so-called right so I
would make an appeal to everyone in the
church to have a serious introspection
MH and a serious
confession not in terms of a confession
to a priest but an acknowledgment of
wrong towards towards the neighbor and
towards God
yeah because when even in in the
writings of the Old Testament Joseph or
any one of them that were tempted to do
something they said how can I do this
sin against God yes
yes when in actual fact you're going to
do something to man you're actually
doing it to
God so repentance Martin is very
important you should bring all of Heaven
that is possible to bring into your
present life he would lift man from the
lowest degradation of sin up to Purity
again and restore to him his moral image
when the Apostle saw the indifference of
Those whom Christ made such an infinite
sacrifice he inquires who has Bewitched
you that you should not obey the
truth there's a power that takes hold of
of the senses of men and women that
perverts their ideas so that they do not
appreciate the love of Christ you cannot
afford to sin the wages of sin is death
we must show to the World by our lives
and character that Christ has not died
for our sins in vain and when we place
ourselves in right relationship to God
then we become living channels of light
to the world Christ had said you are the
light of the world is the world in
darkness oh Darkness who's going
to bring the final
message to humanity the people that
adhere to or cooperate with God okay and
if you cooperate with God the Bible says
here are they that keep the Commandments
and hold to the testimony and have the
faith of Jesus isn't that what it says y
so in order to qualify for the latter
rain now is the time to make right
there's no other time now is the time to
make peace I was with a brother
once and we were walking along a
fence and another man appeared on the
other side of the
fence and I greeted the man on the other
side of the
fence but this person didn't even turn
around the other one walking with you
yes didn't even didn't even turn
around and then we chat I chatted with
the man through the fence and then he
left and I asked
him did you do you know the man this is
your neighbor have you met him before he
says no he's my brother he's a real
brother I said oh okay he hadn't spoken
to him in
years yeah in
years now
probably the brother did something that
hurt him
and maybe the other brother was at
fault but shouldn't we try and make
amends and
forgive would how hard is it it's hard
but what would Jesus have done in that
situation would he walk and just
ignore if it was his brother probably
not right don't think so no I don't
think you would have done it all right
Martin so here's another point if you
have anything against a
brother and uh you haven't made it right
then go and make it right mhm if you
have wronged a brother go and make it
right what does the Bible say when you
go for a foot
washing yeah make right with the brother
if you know that there's a problem and
if you don't you bring condemnation upon
yourself self now is that only for a
foot washing how much more so for the
final events that will be happening in
this world MH so let's wrap this
up sanctification is not the work of a
moment an hour a day but of a
lifetime it is not gained by a happy
flight of feeling but is the result of
constantly dying to sin and constantly
living for Christ wrongs cannot be
writed nor reformations wrought in the
character by feeble intermittent
efforts it is only by long persevering
effort s displine Stern conflict that we
shall
overcome we know not one day how strong
will be our conflict the next so long as
Satan Reigns we shall have self to
subdue besetting sins to overcome so
long as life shall last there will be no
stopping place no point which we can
reach and say I have fully attained
sanctification is the result of a
lifelong
obedience what message do you
have for the people living in this final
generation well definitely don't you
cannot say I have attained you cannot
say I have attained
and if you cannot say you have attained
then that means that you must earnestly
seek to attain it that's it right and if
you earnestly seek you will find that
there are many things that need to be
corrected many things you have to look
very intently into the
mirror and Now's the Time to make right
with those that you don't actually want
to so much
okay so Martin so if I have offended you
in the last week May I apologize and if
I did the same I apologize as well okay
is that enough or does it go beyond to
those that you do not know and that you
do not necessarily want to reconcile
with so Brothers and Sisters in Christ
now is the time to make right the Lord
is coming very very very soon we are
living in the final moments of Earth's
history and this is a very very serious
issue if that door hasn't been fully
opened open it now let's
pray Heavenly
Father we are living in the closing
moments and soon there will be a loud
cry and then the end will
come help us to be not only part of the
loud
cry but to be a partaker of the Heavenly
nature is my prayer in Jesus name amen
[Music]
amen